so everybody is talking about large
language models and there's this model
Avalanche that's happening around
multimedia so what's next there's text
images sound and video now you might
think all this is sci-fi but it's not we
actually did this in a really cool Area
sports entertainment in fact we can bind
all this together to create this AI
highlights system in fact how often do
nerds win an Emy
award now that I've told you the big
picture I now want to show you how all
this works so imagine you're watching a
game it could be very frustrating
because a game is going on and then you
join it somewhere in the middle right so
here's the start and here's the end as
you're watching the game there's all
this text and stats that's being created
then there's many images and still shots
that coming in about your favorite
players from there you can hear and
listen to the crowd cheer as all these
plays are happening and then there's
videos so all the videos are coming in
and they're showing um all the action
that's happening as the game is pro
progressing but you joined here so
you've missed all this content but lucky
for you we have this AI highlight system
that's finding all of these different
indicators so let's start with text here
so over on um the art side where we
combine Art and Science together with
creativity I'm going to connect the dots
and show you how we take the text right
we have these feed foral neural networks
that interpret the text and it and it
has all these different encodings and it
passes It Forward into what we call a
large language model and the job of the
large language model is to take a prompt
or an instruction so it knows what to do
and it produces this novel text so it
can explain what's happening in this
action that you're trying to catch up to
then we go into images so in images we
have convolutional neural networks and
what these do is it has these con
convolutions right where it takes pixels
and it puts them together makes them
smaller into a feature Vector pulls it
together and it feeds It Forward right
and we take all of that and we can use
what it's called a diffusion model and
now a diffusion model it's learned how
to introduce noise and how to remove
noise but this is how we Blend images
together we can take a piece of text and
influence what the image comes out and
looks like now we're on to sound which
we have here so there's crowd here
there's commentator voice that happens
and we want to interpret that so we have
all these building blocks called
recurrent neuron networks or residual
neural networks and what this does is it
pushes forward memory or it pushes back
memory to fluence the outcomes of what
the neural network is trying to predict
and we can take those pieces and build
what are called generative adversarial
networks or Gans and we have a generator
that produces the novel sound and then
we have a discriminator and it wants to
discern between what's been produced and
what is real and if it can't
discriminate between the two the
algorithm has done its job right and now
we we're off into the video which is
really an emerging field uh but I would
like to look at what's called lstms or
long short-term memories which is
another version right of this science
part right and what the long short-term
memory does is it has a memory so it can
remember what happened many plays ago
and then it's easier for it to catch you
up but we can take those you know lstms
and create the lvms which are long large
Vision models and these are composed of
different encoders and decoders and you
might have a tension head so it knows
what to focus in on whenever it's trying
to produce um a video now you might be
wondering you know if you play Fantasy
Football how can all of this help me
well if you use and connect the dots
together this can help you win your
league and summarize all the content
video sound and text about your player
so you can see it all at one place if
you're in banking it could also tell you
what stocks are going to Boom or bust by
just reading all of the different
articles about your said stocks if
you're insurance and your claim adjust
you might want to know about the weather
or what's happening in the news cycle so
that you can better determine how do you
adjust different claims and this could
be forc multiplied together with all
this multimedia to give you this
insightful piece now what I would
suggest you do is to get your hands
dirty and to touch all of these
different types of algorithms build it
deploy it right um because there's many
different cloud services of which you
can do that to today and I think the
sooner you do it the better because
gener AI on the multimedia space is here
for you and it's just going to grow and
it can help create content and
ultimately catch you up in any action
that you might have
missed thanks for watching before you
leave please remember to click like And
subscribe